good morning Hank it's Wednesday the
beckoning of lovely was so lovely thanks
to everyone who was there I want to talk
today about my top 5 zombie apocalypses
I've been thinking about zombie
apocalypses a lot lately
here's a broad observation hank we're in
an absolute golden age of zombie
apocalypses and i think i might be
related to the high unemployment rate
and the general feeling of malaise
I think what's bad for people is good
for zombies which makes me wonder are
zombies people I mean I know they're not
human anymore they're sort of X humans
but our X human still people I don't
know that's one of the things I love
about zombie apocalypse is they ask the
big questions number 5 Pride and
Prejudice and Zombies which includes one
of the great first lines in American
literature it is a truth universally
acknowledged that a zombie and
possession of brains must be in want of
more brains two reasons I love this so
much first it still feels like a Jane
Austen novel even though it's about
zombies it's like Jane Austen's zombie
apocalypse which to a nerd like me is
just heaven and second even though you
keep thinking it's gonna feel like a
stick it never does that novel is
astonishingly readable the only reason
it's not higher on the list I feel like
it was a little short on zombies in an
ideal zombie apocalypse novel I want to
see these two one two one paragraph two
zombie killing ratio number four
The Walking Dead no not yes that one the
comic I don't want to sound like an
originalist but it's much better than
the TV show small-town cop brilliant
illustrations and most importantly the
right kind of zombies there are two
kinds of zombie apocalypse so they're
the kind of zombie apocalypses in which
all people who die regardless of how
they die are reanimated as zombies and
then they're the kind of zombie
apocalypses in which only some dead
people are reanimated as zombies usually
people who have been infected by some
kind of virus that in my opinion is the
superior zombie apocalypse because I
would score the zombie apocalypse is all
about exposing the fragility of human
social orders and I think it is done
better when it is a specific kind of
death that leads to this total collapse
because that's more like what's going to
actually happen everything my opinion
number three George Romero's 1968 film
Night of the Living Dead now that's
going to be extremely controversial
because every
places that at number one why because it
basically invented zombies although that
film never uses the word zombies I mean
zombies are originally like a Haitian
folklore tradition but George Romero's
zombies look a lot more like the zombies
we see today than anything that came
before
aside from maybe I am Legend is the most
influential zombie work of all time so
why am i ringing it solo simple wrong
kind of zombies it's like the boring
shuffle azam bees not the awesome viral
zombies number 2 left 4 dead 2 not left
4 dead 1 left 4 dead 2 why because it is
the only zombie apocalypse video game in
which you can listen to the best zombie
apocalypse song of all time Jonathan
Coulton Zrii your brains plus there is a
lot of zombie killing like in any zombie
apocalypse video game the ideal ratio of
minutes played to zombies killed is like
1 to 80 and left 4 dead 2 comes very
close to that number 1 I mentioned it
earlier not Shaun of the Dead that's
number 6 on my with sorry fanboys number
1 I am Legend the 1954 novel by Richard
Matheson basically invented everything
awesome about zombie apocalypses and
they had the right kind of zombies
vaguely vampiric but the right kind Hank
if it hadn't been for Matheson's novel
we might not even be worried about
disease apocalypsis we might still be
focused on boring apocalypse is like
meteors and food shortages and yes I
think me or apocalypses are boring I'm
probably inviting a media or apocalypse
by saying that but I don't care it's
true world if you end that way it's
super cliche Hank great song on Monday I
will see you on Friday sometimes my
gesticulations are like I'm a cop at an
intersection and you should go this way
and y'all should go over here I should
just turn the video off